foreign
[Music]
and welcome to another video the idea
for this video occurred to me randomly
this morning while I was in the shower
so cannot guarantee that it'll be the
greatest video I've ever made but
hopefully it turns out halfway decent
now those of you who are in touch with
the Chess World probably know uh that
the pro chess League also known as the
PCL has uh completed its second week of
regular season action the PCL is a rapid
team competition that's held on
chess.com it features some of the
strongest teams ever assembled across
the entire world a lot of the top
players are participating Magnus Carlson
pretty unknown player representing the
Canada chess brassy car Nakamura is also
playing for the Gotham Knights Levy
rosman's New York team I'm also playing
for my hometown team the Charlotte
cobras unfortunately we have lost our
first two matches and if you lose three
matches in the regular season you're out
of the PCL so our back is against the
wall and we're gonna keep fighting next
week you should definitely tune in the
matches happen Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday and Friday and I will link in
the description to this video an article
an informational article that contains
all of the info and schedule that you
need to know it's broadcast on Twitch
and on YouTube I'm mostly commentating
when I'm not playing so the PCL
definitely worth a watch if you haven't
already tuned in but the point of this
video isn't just to chill out for the
PCL I think there's also an instructive
component now what I've done for the
last couple of hours is sift through all
of the games from the first two weeks
with an eye toward finding some of the
most instructive end games in particular
I like the end games that occur in Rapid
games because both players by the time
move 40 rolls around I usually have just
a couple of seconds on their clock so
you actually see a lot of very strong
players committing uncharacteristic
mistakes in the end game which they nor
they wouldn't make if they had more time
on the clock we know that the best way
to learn is from the mistakes of others
it's a lot more painful than learning
from your own mistake so what I've done
for this video is assemble the five most
instructive and most entertaining end
games that we saw in the first two weeks
of the pro chess League we're going to
look at these end games one by one these
aren't just Pawn end games or Rook end
games and games of various kinds my
endgame series is still going to
continue so this is kind of a
supplementary video that will hopefully
give you uh some more general advice on
playing the end game I play my cards
right hopefully both more advanced
players will benefit as well as newer
players I'll try to share a couple of
General pieces of end game feedback and
I'll give you plenty of opportunities to
pause the video and test your Tactical
skills and of course your overall end
game skills as well so we'll get through
as many games as we can I have five
prepared but if the video is going too
long we might only get to three or four
so without further Ado let's jump in and
start with a pretty basic but
nonetheless very instructive example and
right before we jump in just wanted to
clarify that I don't have the time to
cover every single detail of these end
games so I absolutely encourage you to
analyze along with me if you have
questions you can leave them in the
comments but you can also analyze with
an engine so I will gloss over some
variations that otherwise I would
include just because I want to kind of
get through the main points I want to
hit on the main instructive points of
each game and I want to get through as
many games as we can
so here we go our first example is an
end game that happened in a game between
a very strong Indian Grandmaster
naryanan who was facing International
Master Demonte cornet and Cornett had
played a fantastic game defending uh
against a raging Initiative for like 30
moves and by move 44 they reached the
end game that is in front of you this is
a same colored Bishop end game obviously
we haven't gotten there yet in my
endgame series but you evaluate these
types of end games much the same that
you would any other end game like a pawn
end game or Rook end game you calculate
the material you take a look at which
side has the more active pieces and you
examine both sides potential for
creating past pawns and this is a pretty
Elementary type of end game because the
pawn structure is largely symmetrical on
both flanks neither side has the
capacity to create a past Pawn but it's
very clear that white has the domination
when it comes to piece activity White's
pieces both the king and the bishop are
a lot more active than their
counterparts particularly White's King
which is oh so close to infiltrating
either the queen side or the king side
Black's King is just holding White's
King at Bay uh the kings are actually in
opposition
White's Bishop is also more active than
its vis-a-vis because it's pressuring
the F7 Pawn that is a long-term Target
when you're looking at same colored
Bishop end games you want generally want
your opponent's pawns to be on the same
color of your Bishop because then those
pawns are a lot easier to attack and if
Black's King steps away then white wins
the game immediately with King F King F6
picking up both of the king side pawns
but of course all of these General
considerations are subsumed by concrete
analysis and often what happens is that
you look at an end game and you feel
like one side is has got to be winning
because the pieces are much more active
but you actually have to calculate
concretely a fortress can completely
nullify all of these General positional
considerations which is actually the
case here for all of White's advantages
there is absolutely no way for white to
infiltrate unless black is forced to
move her King and black is not forced to
move her King black as a bishop the
bishop has plenty of squares and all
black has to do to draw this game game
is Just Shuffle the bishop really on any
Square as long as you don't allow
White's King to infiltrate D5 and C6 so
Bishop B7 for example is uh perhaps the
easiest way to draw white is powerless
right bringing the king back doesn't
help because C5 is uh covered by the
pawn B4 is futile as well black will
simply trade and play a move like Bishop
C6 that doesn't help the only tricky
move that white can try is Bishop D5
offering an exchange of Bishops and as
you'll see in the night ending videos
Bishop endgame videos another very
important aspect of good end game
technique is the constant evaluation of
what happens in the event that the minor
pieces are traded right you always have
to keep your peripheral vision on who
benefits in the events of upon end games
because trades are so common and here it
may appear that white has to be winning
in the Platinum game but in fact white
isn't black and draw by declining the
trade with a move like Bishop C C8 but
even taking on T5 results in an
immediate draw because after King D7
black maintains the opposition it may
seem that with a move before white is
forcing black into zugsvong because
after a before a before black runs out
of waiting moves remember from the pawn
and game video black has to move for
King if B5 then of course King C5 but
the specifics of the position again
always supersede these General
considerations and it turns out that
after King C7 it's actually a pretty
Elementary draw because white cannot go
King E6 the F7 Pawn is the unsung hero
of Black's entire defensive construction
white has to take the roundabout route
but black is in time to make to E8 you
don't care how passive your king is
white has nothing to attack King G7 is
similarly futile because after King E7
doesn't matter who has the opposition
black will just Shuffle between E8 and
E7 add infinitum white will never be
able to play H5 and even if white quote
unquote gets can gets the opposition
it's not going to matter because if
white drops back to F6 black then
reclaims the opposition and pursues
White's King to the edge of the world no
matter where it goes Black's King is
right there and this is an obvious drop
but Cornett with just a couple of
seconds left on her clock makes a very
understandable move and this move
violates a rule that my coach shared
with me many many years ago it's a rule
that sounds incredibly General it sounds
vacuous it sounds like it you know is
this really uh an effective way to play
The Young and yet it is right my
experience has convinced me that this
rule is incredibly enduring and
effective across a wide variety of end
games and the rule simply states that
you should not move unnecessary you
should not make unnecessary pawn moves
in the end game put another way every
Pawn that you move in the end game you
should have a clear reason that you're
moving it and creating a one move threat
is not a reason grabbing space isn't
really a valid reason to move upon in
the end game and the reason that you
have to be so careful about pawn moves
is because there are tremendously
weakening when you don't have a lot of
pieces left when you move upon in the
end game You Are by definition weakening
squares but more importantly you're
often bringing the pawn onto a more
vulnerable Square the further the pawns
go from your side of the board the
harder they are to defend and when you
don't have a lot of pieces left you
might end up losing those spawns this is
exactly what happens here cornet plays
the move B5 and this is a decisive
mistake because it puts the pawn on a
light Square where it can be much more
easily attacked not only by White's
Bishop but also by whites King because a
pathway has now opened up to the queen
side so this both makes the pawn more
vulnerable and allows white king to
infiltrate Black's weaknesses with King
D5 and King C5 first of course why we'll
have to get this bishop off of C5 the
second thing that it does is that now
every Pawn end game is going to be
losing for black and so narayana
responds with a very accurate move he
plays the move Bishop D5 now the
situation has changed and in the events
of the trade white is just going to
reach C5 and black will lose either one
or both of her Queen Side Pawn so for
example King t7 King C5
and black can try to initiate the pawn
race but this is like you know a Ferrari
racing against a Ford black is not even
close
and very importantly anytime black plays
F5 white takes on poisson this is called
a deep freeze the G5 Pawn is deep
freezing blacks uh F7 and G6 pawns
making it incredibly difficult for black
to even get a past Pawn so the pawn end
game is now out of the question Coronet
is forced to move for Bishop back and
now the second very important phase of
White's winning strategy pause the video
this will be your first end game task
this is a move that is automatic for
good end game players but again you
shouldn't feel bad if you get a move
wrong because that's the whole point
that's why you study end games so see if
you can figure this move out in just a
couple of seconds
foreign
colored Bishop end games especially when
you have an opposing Pawn that's on the
color of your Bishop that's an
incredibly valuable asset and you want
to make sure when possible that things
stay that way this is what white does
with the move before this fixes the pawn
on a light square right it's hard to
shoot at a moving Target and here the
pawn will be totally immobilized and all
that white has to do now is clear the
pathway for the king once the king
reaches C5 the bishop can drop back to
the F1 A6 diagonal white will pick up
the pawn and win the game and that is
exactly how things unfold black is
totally powerless because she is too
passive after the trade cornet waits
around with Bishop E8 white drops the
bishop back and there are some
interesting subtle tastes here that I
could delve into but we'll skip so here
for example the most direct way to win
would have been the immediate King D5 uh
but Mariana was a little bit worried
that Blackwood essentially trade all of
the kingside pawns and once that happens
even if white will win the B5 on which
he will remember that if there are no
other pawns left then black could try to
give the bishop away for White's last
remaining Pawn King and Bishop versus
King is a draw so narianan shuffles his
pieces around and avoids this scenario
he first plays Bishop E2 he gets his
Bishop around to D3 and only now after
cornet moves her Bishop back King D7 by
the way would have been a little bit
more resilient but then the king would
have infiltrated F6 and white is still
handily winning but after Bishop D7 King
D5 white has avoided the situation if
black plays F6 then white takes on G6
this is in fact what happened and now
white actually keeps both past pawns
alive fg5 hg5 now the king slides over
to C5 the bishop moves back to D3 and
black is unable to get to G6 with her
King if Black's Bishop moves away from
the diagonal then white captures with
the King and if white if black stays in
the diagonal then white takes the pawn
with the bishop and because the bishop
is hanging black is again unable to
reach G6 this is what happened in the
game white returned to D3 and cornet
resigned the game because the b-pawn is
just going to run up the board the final
detail that I wanted to share is a
option the black had after King to D5 so
you might have noticed that rather than
playing F6 and simply giving up the pawn
black could have tried to create a
passer with F5 and forced white into
taking on poisson but in fact white has
an even easier approach here than taking
on passant which does win this position
is winning even though even though black
is able to trade all of the pawns you
can convince yourself of this by using
the engine but white is essentially able
to roll out the red carpet we will
analyze these types of Bishop end games
at length in a subsequent end game video
but even simpler in this position it's
actually to go back to E5
then White's plan of action is very
simple black has to stay on this
diagonal to keep the pawn defended the
bishop drops back to E2 now moving the
king is out of the question because
white infiltrates either to F6 or comes
around to C5 so black has to stay with
the bishop and now white pushes H5 this
is a simple breakthrough breaking down
Black's Pawn chain that's all there is
to it and on the next move you are going
to go around and pick up the pawn on F5
and essentially get the same type of
position that they got in the game black
has to Simply wait around Bishop G6 and
that's it white takes on F5 the pawn end
game is losing and here the simplest is
just to get the king over to C5 much
like white did in the game and pick up
the second Pawn so F5 was slightly more
resilient but here white could double
back to E5 and win the king Side Pawn
First in the game black played F6 and
gave up the pawn but all of coronet's
problems in this end game stemmed from
that decisive mistake in the initial
position so do not push unnecessary
pawns and particularly in Bishop end
games you should be very sensitive about
putting your pawns uh on squares where
they can be attacked by the opposing
side's Bishop from White's perspective I
think the most instructive was first of
all to offer the bishop trade right when
a pawn is pushed the situation changes
and you should reassess what happens in
the event of a trade but also as
important was the move before fixing the
pawn on a light Square so that you can
more easily attack it with your PC
and in this way an Ariana was able to
win the game okay on we go to our second
end game and these end games won't have
any particular order I want to give you
a a wide variety of interesting end game
positions so let's examine a more
tactical end game now what's funny is
that I was commentating this game live
this was a game between Karina and
bartumova uh International master and V
pranav uh a newly crowned Grandmaster
from India who some people who are
watching this should be familiar with
I've played him a dozen hundreds of
times probably by now in Blitz super
super talented player and pranav has the
black pieces here
and he is completely winning he is
technically down in exchange but he's
got two pawns for that exchange but all
of that doesn't matter look at this Pawn
on D2 it is a passer and what stands
between it and promotion is this
miserable Rook on D1 Black's pieces are
maximally active and the winning
approach is of course to dislodge The
Rook from D1 by attacking it with the
Knight so that's exactly what pranav
does he plays the obvious move Knight to
C3 now as a sneak preview you can see
the question mark popping up on the
screen so you know already that
something is wrong with this move is
there a way to do the same exact thing
but from a different angle well yes
there is the move Knight F2 does indeed
win the game for black if the Rook moves
then black simply promotes and emerges
up a piece if black does not react then
white does not react then black takes
the rook and wins easily the quote
unquote most resilient move is Queen B7
check but this is a paper tiger because
the king is able to hide out on H6 and
most importantly consider the placement
of Black's Queen it's placed on an Ideal
position both from an attacking but also
from a defensive perspective because
it's guarding the h8 square so black can
safely take White's rook and has nothing
to fear on the king side white has one
check it can be easily blocked by the
queen and here white is simply out of
checks but most importantly this would
be Checkmate were it not for the
presence of Black's Queen so you should
actually keep that in mind because it
becomes very important in just a couple
of moves what could possibly be the
downside of doing the same thing from
the other side of the board well once
again White's hand is largely forced and
Amber tsumova with her last seconds
finds the correct move she gives the
check on B7 but after King H6 we seem to
have the same exact scenario who cares
whether the Knight is on C3 or F2 it
doesn't change anything Black's Queen is
still on the same spot but this really
is the beauty of endgame tactics right
even more so than middle game tactics
and game tactics really often don't
subject themselves to intuitive logic
your intuitive part of your brain could
be screaming that one thing is the case
but the tactics often show otherwise and
here turns out that there is a beautiful
beautiful difference between the
placement of the Knight on F2 and on C3
because here white gets an additional
defensive resource which actually forces
black to be the one to find a series of
only Moves In order to draw the game as
crazy as that sounds so great time to
pause the video and figure out the
hidden resource that allows white to
turn the tables
so the best way to solve a puzzle like
this is probably process of elimination
right you literally just consider every
legal move
and we already know that a move like
Queen C8 does not do the trick this
literally transposes into the same
position we had from the Knight F2
variation so the only difference is that
here the Knight and the queen are
aligned and white is able to pin the
Knight with the crazy proof Queen B2
which I think is a move which may have
even occurred to Karina it's not a
particularly challenging move in and of
itself right you're pinning in the
Knight which means that Knight takes D1
loses the game because black drops the
queen but subconsciously it's very easy
to rule this move out because black has
of course an intermediate check on F2
and after the king moves the Knight
safely takes the rook and black wins the
gateway to Second what was the queen
doing on D4 in that other line well
guess what it was guarding the h8 square
here white literally has mate in one
Queen goes from where where was it start
where did it start it goes from F3 to B7
to B2 to h8 ridiculous geometry here by
the White Queen and after Queen F2
checking H3 in order to draw the game
black actually has to find the move
Queen to F3 everything else it loses
because if you play some other move if
you play Move like Queen E3 then white
again goes to B8 and starts hunting the
black king down this threatens made on
h8 if black tries to defend then the
deflection sacrifice wins the game Rook
takes D2 is really pretty Queen D2 Queen
h8 is checkmate and if black defense
with the King then white zigzags her way
first to C7 then to d8 what's the idea
of the staircase well now you can pick
up the pawn on D2 because the queen and
the Rook are linked up so in this
position black has to find the
cold-blooded move Queen F3 which allows
white to draw in a variety of ways the
most clinical of which is actually to
still go to B8 threatening the maid on
h8 and black has nothing better than to
force a Perpetual check with Queen G4
and queen E2 don't go back to the first
rank because you give the Rook away with
check black has nothing better to do
king G7 again loses to the staircase
mechanism so black would be the one who
would have had to be precise after this
incredible move Queen B2 and what this
teaches us is that well as much of a
cliche as this may sound like you really
should never give up in the end game I
think a lot of players they tend to
associate end games with lack of
resources lack of defensive resources
and you may think of the end game as a
phase of the game where it's much harder
to trick your opponent and partially
that's true but that doesn't mean that
tactics or mating ideas are absent from
the end game and when there are Queens
on the board there are always mating
patterns that is just a thing you should
Hammer into your head and can we blame
Karina for missing queen B2 with three
seconds absolutely not I would have
never found this move but nonetheless it
exists and it teaches us a lot about the
abundance of tactical resources even
when they appear to be least likely
Karina played Queen H1 and after Knight
takes D1 pranav was obviously able to
win the game he delivered to check on F2
and played Queen E1 it would be nice if
the queen could teleport itself today I
guess that wouldn't have helped because
now black has the equivalent mate on H1
and black made a second Queen easily
dodged the checks and won the game
so really incredible tactical resource
in the unlikeliest of moments okay on we
go to our next example this one is also
very very tactical and very pretty it is
a game that occurred between two of the
stronger teams in the PCL the Garden
State passers uh who have Samuel sevyan
their board one and uh the Levitt off
chess Wizards which is composed of a lot
of very strong Russian and Bella Russian
GMS one of whom is Dennis lazovic he's a
very exciting young player from Belarus
2541 is his rating but you can toss that
into the trash can he's definitely over
2600 strength so in this game lasovic
has black against Savion and they've
reached the pawn and game that is in
front of you it is black to play and
once again as is going to be the case in
all of the end games that we are
examining today both sides are in acute
time pressure and have mere seconds to
make very complicated decisions so I'll
make it a little bit easier for you the
big question here for black is between
keeping the stat this quo which
essentially means doing nothing and what
that means in a pawn end game is moving
the king we've already learned that you
should avoid unnecessary pawn moves so
the default move is King back to E7 but
of course if you've watched the pawn and
game videos carefully you should already
sense what the big worry here is for
black which is that the black king being
more passive than its counterpart and
being the king that is in opposition
is going to get shouldered it's going to
get zugsvonged continuously and white is
ultimately going to make his way to the
king side and pick off Black's
vulnerable kingside Ponce he's gonna do
that by playing King to C7
right if the King goes back to E8 then
white drops back to D6 this is
shouldering vice versa King E8 King E6
King d8 and uh if black continues to
dilly dally well there we go right King
E6 uh King Yan and King f8 and white is
already winning the game by bringing the
king down to G7 but upon cluster
examination you should realize that
black is not entirely powerless black
has a lever that he can pull and he can
pull it in a variety of different
moments and that lever is the pawn
breakthrough F5 forcing a mass trade of
Pawns and transforming the position into
an entirely different type of Pawn end
games lazovic decides to pull the lever
in the initial position he plays the
move F5 here
and we will start by considering how the
game unfolded then when we finish the
analysis we will go back to the initial
position and the correct approach will
make a lot more sense once you realize
why the move F5 should have been a
decisive mistake that lost lazovic the
game as we will see there are many more
Adventures to be had here well white has
to start by trading initiating the
trades right white cannot ignore because
then black will take and create a past
Pawn of his own so white has to trade
and again if you ignore then black will
play F4 and E4 and white will simply
lose the game so Savion accedes to the
trades and we we reach this position
so it's easy to get overwhelmed in these
types of Pawn end games because there's
a lot of directions that the king can
take right and it gets complicated but
it's actually simpler to break this down
than it appears this is a pawn race in
the making and the reason I see that
quickly is because with his next move
King to D5 white gets opposition and
will ultimately try to dislodge to
dislodge Black's King away from its
protection of the E5 Pawn using
zougsvang Black's only counter play in
that case will be to go after the H3
Pawn if both of those pawns are
liquidated we're gonna get a pawn race
between the epon and the H fund but
before we get that pawn race both sides
have a series of waiting moves that they
need to exhaust and this is exactly what
happens lazovic plays the move E4
pushing the pawn forward but savian
freezes the pawn with E3 and hopefully
you can see where this is going
especially if you watched the video on
Pawn races and waiting moves black has
only one waiting move remaining that is
H5 and white completes his waiting moves
last forcing black into zugsbon H4 is
played and Black's King has to abandon
the E4 Pawn now I should note that
something similar would have happened if
black had started with H5 here white can
play H4 reaching essentially the same
position or white could start with E4
check and after King F4 force zougsvong
with H4 and again you get the same
position from the game instead lasovic
pushed D4 not exactly the same position
but the nature of the pawn race will be
essentially identical well black has to
take the plunge and play King G4 Savion
captures on e4 and black captures on H4
now the first thing that you need to do
in a pawn race is simply count the Tempe
whose Pawn is further Advanced well
mathematically black should be the first
one to promote in a pawn race like if
you calculate abstractly white moves the
king black moves the king E4 H4 E5 H3
e6h2 E7 H1 incidentally I put the white
King on D5 or where black will promote
with check but clearly black should be
on the aggressive side of the pawn race
black should definitely not be losing
here but you might remember that one of
the crucial rules of Pawn races is to
not forget that you can use your king
not only to assist your Pawn but also to
obstruct and slow down the progress of
the enemy Pawn this is particularly true
when the opposing side has a corner pawn
and the king is stuck in front of the
pawn the black king cannot move to the
right side of the board there is no
right side of the board and so the Savvy
winning move is King E4 to F4 you're
taking up as position but that's not why
this move is good it's good because
you're not allowing Black's King to step
away from the pawn Black's King has to
remain on the H file and this gives
white a very very important tempo Savion
uses this Tempo to start the progress of
his own Pawn lasovic does the same and
here we reach the critical position of
this game again there were about five
seconds on the clock for Sam he took
three of them on what may seem like the
most natural move possible Right your
hand is reaching to make this move and
yet there is only one way to move uh
only one way to win and it involves
making what to me at least seems like
the most unnatural move especially if
you start calculating and therein lies
the beauty of Pawn end games in general
but this end game in particular because
it illustrates a very very instructive
idea uh that you have to understand if
you want to handle Pawn races
successfully so pause the video this is
a big big moment let's see if you can
improve on Sam sebian's play and find
the winning approach
oh build some water on my phone there
so I'm kind of regretting saying that
you know the correct move is unnatural
because natural means different things
to different people so hopefully you
were able to toss that in the trash
there are two logical candidate moves
for white the first is to push the pawn
the second is to try to keep Black's
King caged in with the move King to F3
maintaining opposition and trying to buy
yourself as much time as possible for
the progress of your epon and Savion
makes this move he plays King F3 and to
me this move seems more natural because
there doesn't appear to be a downside of
the move King F3 you're just forcing
Black's King further down and if you
look at this position carefully you'll
notice that King G1 can be met with King
G4 and white picks up the pawn so we're
home free E5 except we're not home free
the problem is the Black Bush is to
spawn down at H3 and if white continues
to keep Black's King boxed in yeah
congratulations you're gonna stop black
from promoting but what what's gonna
happen a scenario that we did explore in
the pawn race video is that black is now
stalemated and in order to unstalemate
Black you have to move the king away
allowing black to step to G1 or G2 and
promote his pawn and in that case black
promotes first and is able to eke out
the draw after E7 this is simply a
stalemate King G3 black plays King G1
and it's crucial that black promotes
first because if White had promoted
first then obviously Queen E1 would be
Checkmate but here black is tosses
White's gang away from G3 and makes an
easy draw so it turns out that King F3
is the move which gives away the win and
the correct move is the immediate E5 now
how on Earth does this work because
while you're allowing King G2 and with
his last seconds Sam undoubtedly
calculated to the position after both
sides promote simultaneously but it's
crucial to remember that just because
there are two Queens on the board does
not mean that the game ends the first
thing you need to do is look for skewers
you should be familiar with a lot of
situations for example if Black's King
were to be on D5 here white would win
the game with a diagonal check skewering
and picking up the queen
here the situation is different because
the king and the queen are adjacent so
Queenie Ford check is not effective it
doesn't win black screen Black's King is
able to stay pegged to the queen but
here the win comes from a different
Source entirely turns out the blacks
came when it's this close to the corner
and when the queen is this confined
there is a very important idea that
involves
forcing Black's King onto the first Rank
and then actually making a quiet
Preparatory move which will lead to
inevitable Checkmate the most precise
win is Queenie to check the king is
forced onto G1 King H3 results in Maiden
2 Queen G4 check and queen G3 is a very
pretty mating construction uh and one
that is worth remembering because the
queen is blocking the king's only Escape
Square so the King has to take the
plunge and now white plays the
incredibly Zen move King G3
and again you should sear this position
into your memory because it occurs very
very frequently in all sorts of Pawn
races that liquidate into Queen end
games black is no checks well black does
have checks but all of them lose the
queen there are no stale Matrix either
if black gives the check here of course
taking with the queen would be foolish
but white takes with a king black is
King H1 there is no way to stop the
Myriad of Checkmate threats no matter
where Black's Queen moves it might stop
one Checkmate threat but there will be
at least two others that will lead to
Checkmate this is an obvious win for
white so a very instructive example of a
situation in which with just seconds on
the clock Sam decided that because the
pawns promote simultaneously it's
automatically a draw with just another
five or ten seconds I think he would
have understood that this is a win
instead he tries to keep black skin
confined but remember that when you do
that and when your opponent has no other
pawns left there is always going to be
the threat of stalemate but we're not
done with this position hopefully you're
able to understand why white was able to
win this game he didn't win the game uh
how I would have been able to win this
game instead he played this extra move
King F3 and after King h2e5h3
the king steps into the checking zone of
the H Pawn which means that black will
promote with check and actually if white
pushes E6 immediately then yes white
promotes first but here black promotes
with check this is the other important
corollary of the move King F3 so it's
not only a mistake because it allows
black to stalemate his own King but also
because it steps into the checking zone
of the h-pawn allowing black to promote
with check and worm his way out of the
confined space that the king finds
itself in
so the winning move here was the
immediate E5 let's rewind back to the
initial position where lazovic pulled
the plug and basically played the move
F5 so instead the draw was given by the
move King E7 and we need to pause after
King C7 King E6 and King d8 right here
it seems that white is making great
progress and getting the king forcibly
to the king side but in this very
instance it is the proper time to push
F5 when the white king is the furthest
away from the E5 Pawn that's when you
force the liquidation of the pawns and
the reason should be pretty clear if we
compare this position to the position
which occurred in the game and the
position which occurred in the game was
this one here the king is on C6 there
the king is on d8 so here the king is
able to make contact with the E5 Pawn in
one move
but if we compare that to this position
here the white king takes two moves to
make contact with the E5 Pawn now why
does this matter well this matters
because it gives black an extra Tempo to
push the H Pawn as far down as it'll go
which is another rule of Pawn races
which essentially states that when
you're anticipating a pawn race you
should always try to prepare by pushing
your prospective passwords a bit of a
mouthful perspective is in Future Past
Pawn as far as it'll go you should
prepare yourself for the pawn race to
economize and save as many Tempe as
possible here Black Goes H5 white makes
contact with a pawn but black is able to
drive the pawn to H4 this is what black
was not able to do in the game this is
what black was not able to do in the
game white plays King D5 and now black
runs toward the H3 pawn and it's pretty
easy to establish uh that here black is
able to promote first and draws the game
handily if white plays in this position
E3 trying to block the king's path well
then black draws with King E4 now
actually white is the one who has to be
careful
it's still a draw but black will
actually end up winning the H3 Pawn so
again if we compare this position and of
course if white plays H4 then white
loses because of King G4 so white simply
is not able to do everything that he
needs to do
prevent black from playing H4 make
contact with the pawn and push the
e-pawn forward that extra Tempo is the
difference between a draw and a loss and
that is what makes plan end game so
ridiculously devilishly complicated it's
these minor differences but appreciating
these minor differences and really
delving deeply into these types of end
games I think they teach you a lot about
how to play Pawn end games and they help
develop a pretty robust intuition
because a lot of the time when you reach
an end game like this you just don't
have the time to calculate and you're
inevitably going to make mistakes but
you're going to minimize the risk of
those mistakes if you develop a clear
intuition about what is helpful uh and
how you should generally play in these
end games so one of the key takeaways is
that you shouldn't think in general
blocks right it looks like black skin is
getting shouldered but remember that you
don't have to sit idly by you can often
push your pawns not unless there's a
good reason but here there is a good
reason but you should try to do it when
the opposing side's King is on the most
inconvenient square and often that
involves forcing the king to initiate
the shouldering process and then once
the King has reached the eighth rank we
push F5 because blight takes the longest
possible time to get back to black spawn
so it's a little bit of a clunky
explanation but hopefully you found this
end game pretty entertaining I love me
some Pond races and this is no exception
so we're down to two more examples let's
see if we can get through uh both of
them okay let's take a look at another
Bishop n camp let's take a look at
another Bishop end game which occurred
in a game between two incredibly strong
players blocked on Daniel Dash Romanian
Grandmaster who is rated 2 700 feet a on
the nose and georgmeyer super solid GM
from Germany who's beaten a lot of the
top players and you know the last time
this guy lost the game was like 2003 but
here Meyer who has the black pieces is
on the cusp of losing and that's obvious
because white is simply up a pawn white
has an extra Pawn on E5 uh and anytime
you're up a pawn in a single minor piece
end game well that's generally a pretty
good sign but just a couple of seconds
into looking at this position you should
understand the black as a fortress right
again just like in uh our first example
it's one thing to just say that you have
an extra Pawn but that doesn't win you
the game you actually need to make
progress promote that pawn or otherwise
infiltrate with your king and neither of
those scenarios seems remotely possible
so why is that well one of White's big
problems is that the a pawn is on a
light Square so white can't just free
roll with the bishop if you make a
inaccurate move you're immediately going
to allow Bishop B3 and this is just an
immediate draw in fact in order to draw
white has to immediately give up the E
Pawn to deflect this bishop back
obviously King E6 King G6 and white is
fine and after Bishop B6 white has to
play Bishop D1 so one little careless
move and white is on the defensive and
that appears to completely hamstring
White's ability to play for a win the
move H6 is okay it seems to accomplish
something but that's an illusion because
the white king cannot make its way past
Black's King on F7 in fact black can
shift the king to E7
well I can do it even now and this King
on E7 is on a dark Square it can never
be checked and it can never be dislodged
and it's very obvious that white has
zero zero progress to make in fact you
already have to be careful because now
Black's King is suddenly moving up to E6
so it seems that the most the wisest
strategy is just to repeat moves and
that's what Bogdan Daniel Dash does he
brings his King back and they
essentially repeat moves this position
is still winning for white as we'll
discuss uh but it uh results in
three-time repetition they had
previously had this position two other
times uh which I haven't shown you but
this is where the game was automatically
declared a draw by the server but let's
rewind to the initial position white has
an absolutely gorgeous winning sequence
that once again hammers home The
Importance of Being keenly aware of the
role of tactics even when there are
virtually no pieces left on the board
there's a ton of tactics in Pawn end
games in fact Pawn end games are
virtually only tactics and we see that
here as well the way winning approach
involves understanding that the E5 Pawn
can be used as a decoy now we saw
something like that in our initial line
here white uses it as a decoy but not
because he's trying to win because he's
trying to avoid losing but this concept
is a very valuable one because if
Black's King is forced away from F7 then
white takes the pawn on G7 and the
corner Pawn is is free to roam about the
cabin but how do you get a situation
where you can play E6 without allowing
black to take the pawn with the bishop
well this is where you come in let's
pause the video and see if you can
figure out the winning sequence if you
can generate more than just one move if
you can generate the entire line that
would be particularly impressive so feel
free to take a couple of minutes here uh
and I will in the meantime take a sip of
tea and watch you guys torture
yourselves
mwaha
I remember irrationally getting annoyed
at my my chess coach when he would give
me a position and tell me it's 20
minutes of thinking and then I could
hear him making tea in the background
and he would be putting lemon in and
enjoying himself and probably watching
Netflix on the side and here I was
laboring over the position
but hopefully these tasks are a little
bit more enjoyable the winning move is
Bishop G4 this should come to you
naturally because when you have an extra
Pawn the idea of trading Bishops is very
logical and the pawn end game is easy to
evaluate it it's totally losing for
black in fact you can win this several
different ways the easiest is just to go
up and win the G7 Pawn you can also play
King F4
so black has to avoid the bishop trade
with the move Bishop B3 now step two is
to use the pawn as a decoy there it is
now here's the difference
the King has to well the bishop can take
the pawn but that allows the Bishops to
be traded and again
white wins the resulting pod and get so
we're getting somewhere we're forcing
Black's King back to f8 but step three I
think is actually the hardest thing to
see white is playing with fire here
because there is no longer any way to
defend the A4 pawn and you might say oh
I get it let's get our King to G6 let's
get our King to G6 and then let's play
E7 check and take on G7 but just because
you have to pass Pawn does it mean you
win the game remember that your opponent
can actually give away the minor piece
in many cases four your only remaining
Pawn here white has another Pawn
remaining but it's hamstrung it's frozen
and black can easily reach it with his
King so after Bishop C2 I think black is
already winning the engine kind of
fluctuates here but I'm pretty sure
black is already winning because not
only will you not be able to promote but
even if you win the bishop black is now
suddenly the one who promotes white
can't play Bishop E6
so the common technique often is to play
Bishop H5 and Bishop G6 and dislodge the
Bishop from the diagonal but white is
not in time because black plays A2 and
promotes with check so white actually
loses
in this case so you would not really go
into this line if you didn't see the
subsequent move and this is another
opportunity if you didn't have a clear
idea in this position to figure out uh
the brilliant follow-up tactic and I'll
pause for just a couple of seconds here
as well
foreign
approach is another deflection sacrifice
two deflections in the span of five
moves in an end game here this is a
completely different kind of deflection
you're not trying to deflect the king
you're trying to deflect the G7 Pawn
which is not permitting white to reach
the F6 Square that's the promised land
so we now use the H Pawn as the decoy
we're threatening H7 black has to take
and the King moves into F6 and now E7 is
totally Unstoppable black can give the
bishop away for the pawn but here it's
clear that white is winning because
you're just gonna win the remaining
queenside Pawns if black does anything
else if black takes on A4 then the win
is Elementary we give a check and the
king is on a light Square which is so so
valuable here because the bishop is able
to dislodge it and white promotes a
queen nothing the black can do in this
situation Bishop H5 is Unstoppable
so Bishop takes C6 is technically the
most resilient but it loses the game
very straightforwardly as well remember
as in basic point but still important to
note you should never be afraid of a
scenario like this and think that black
will somehow be able to promote their
Pawn you can always just give the bishop
away for the pawn especially if the king
is as far away as it is from the queen
side I feel like I said that in a New
York accent a porn you should you know
you should you should always knew we
should be you know ready to end and give
up you know Bishop Ford wanted much like
I did you know against corpov you know
1984 but hey
uh so anyways I got a little carried
away there but the move H6 is such a
great illustration of the role of
unexpected tactics in the end game and
of the role of just thinking big right
you might always you always want to
think in the form okay this is what I
want to achieve and this could be
completely unrealistic right you should
tell yourself I want to get a king to F6
and you should not rule out that thought
just because there's a Pawn on G7
because you're often uh able to do a lot
more in end games than might seem to be
the case because you don't have a lot of
pieces left and yet your remaining
pieces and pawns are often capable of
great things as they are here the last
thing I'll say is that black and try to
Stave off defeat with Bishop C2 and the
Hasty hdhd7 check actually gives away
the win because here of course the king
is no longer able to infiltrate so all
white needs to do is make the patient
move Bishop H5 which by this point
should be pretty obvious the point is
that after Bishop D3 well now you can
play there's multiple ways to win but
the simplest is to play HG uh and E7 of
course you're stopping King F7 and white
promotes uh the queen if black plays GH
then you transpose back into the uh the
other mating line
so the win here is yielded first by
using the threat of the bishop trade to
dislodge the bishop here's deflection
number one forcing the king away and
deflection number two immediately
afterward clears the path to the F6
square there's the concept of mowing the
lawn that I talked about in uh the
advanced topics Pawn end game video and
this is kind of similar where you use
your pawns to clear a path for your king
which then enables your other Pawn to
promote to a queen okay so we're at 46
minutes here uh what we're gonna do is
go through the last example pretty
quickly I could talk about it for ages
uh we're not going to do that I'm gonna
try to limit myself to five or six
minutes so buckle in so I'm gonna try to
hit on the important points here and our
last end game is a battle between Jaime
Santos latasa Spanish Grandmaster and
olexon Orting a good friend of mine uh
incredibly strong Blitz and bullet
player many of you listening are
probably familiar with that name uh so
portnick has the black pieces here he
also represents the Garden State passers
uh who have sansevian who we saw uh just
earlier on board one now it is white to
play in this position uh Jaime Santos
latasa has the move and he has the
advantage that part is obvious because
he's got the only past pawn and he also
has the capacity to capture the pawn on
G6 if he so desires but what you should
notice here also is that Black's King is
quite far away from White's a pawn so
Jaime Sansa slatasa who was not in time
pressure he was the only player of all
of the ones we looked at today who was
not in time pressure and ironically he
makes the fastest move of anybody he
takes two seconds on his next move and
he pushes the pawn up to A5 and
amazingly this ridiculously natural move
gives away the win right how natural is
it just to push the pawn forward it
seems self-evident the black is not able
to stop this pawn and yet this move
enables black to achieve a beautiful
beautiful draw which Bortnick finds he
was in serious time for sharing it he
was able to find the drawing idea so
first let's take a look at the draw then
we'll rewind and consider how white
should have proceeded there is a very
narrow path actually to winning this
game so what you should immediately rule
out is a move like Rook to A2 because
this is a lost cause you're allowing A6
and ultimately why it's just going to go
around with his King if black tries to
keep White's King at Bay then white
starts mopping up the king side pawns
and you're not going to be able to give
Perpetual check here because the king
will always be able to zigzag its way uh
behind the pawn You're Gonna Lose the G4
pawn and I'll leave this to you to
figure out but you're gonna lose the
game pretty straightforwardly here so
black needs something with a little bit
more meat on the bone and the only
source of counter play that black has
are the g-pawns but the G pawns are
restricted so by process of elimination
Sasha plays Rook to G2 and he he told me
that when he played this move he still
didn't fully see how he was gonna draw
the game but he figured he had no other
defensive ideas and that is a very
effective method especially in time
pressure white continuous pushing he
takes the pawn white continues fishing
and the game seems to be over because if
black stops the pawn from behind as
you're supposed to do white blocks The
Rook with Rook A6 that's it Black's Pawn
is one tempo short g38 queen stopping G2
and if black gives the check then the
king steps away anywhere and again
promotion is Unstoppable and yet it is
in this position that black has just an
incredible resource which is so easy to
miss when you're calculating from a
distance again use process of
elimination and you should find this
move very very quickly pause the video
Maybe for One Last Time and see what you
can come up with here
okay so there's literally only one other
thing that you can do Rook B3 check a
check can be such an effective method in
end games right you don't even have to
understand exactly what the check does
but it often dislodges your opponent's
king and that opens up a wealth of new
defensive possibilities so here's the
rub if white goes to C6 now black plays
Rook A3 and suddenly there is no more
Rook A6 why I can play King B7 but now
black gets the requisite Tempo that he
needs in order to push the pawn one
square further if white plays Rook A6
now then black trades and promote
simultaneously incidentally black can
also sack The Rook immediately and the
g-pawn secures the draw this is a
classic scenario we will talk about this
uh in a dedicated Rook versus Pawn video
or multiple videos because these end
games can get very complicated but here
it's very easy to uh establish that the
threat of promotion a force is white to
give away the Rook for the pawn or or to
keep checking but the king is always
going to go back to the pawn uh when
necessary uh and and threaten G1 equals
Queen
so that is an elementary draw latasa
finds the only way to keep the game
going and that's King to A4
covering the squares on the a file
boardnik has to take the rook and white
promotes to a queen and you might be
aware that queen versus Rook is winning
for the queen right it's a theoretical
win but here there are these two
additional pawns so I think a lot of
players when they if they have black
here would be tempted to just try to
push the pawns but that's actually the
last thing that you want to do first of
all because this blunder is The Rook but
even if it didn't right you're by
pushing the pawns back to our initial
and game principle don't push pawns
unnecessarily because you're gonna end
up weakening them if white can win one
of the pawns then likely he is going to
win the second one boardnick plays The
Very level-headed move Rook F6 common
defensive technique when you've got to
Rook against the queen try to keep your
rook and your king as close together as
possible because that minimizes the risk
of forks as it does here latasa brings
his King over boardneg swings his Queen
over to the G file and now comes the
main aspect of the send game black not
only has a fortress it's not one of
those fortresses where you know you
gotta find a new move every time
literally Black's Rook goes between F3
and F5 between F3 and F5 it's a
beautiful construction it's so unusual
these doubled pawns and create two
anchor squares on the f file what's
important about the file is that it
keeps whites King permanently cut off on
this side of the board white cannot make
any progress and white cannot cause
zugzvong because every time he tries
black just shifts The Rook from F3 to F5
there is no checkmating pattern because
the king will always have the uh G5
square or the H6 square or a some sort
of square white has no way to set up a
mating construction if White's King had
been on G3 then Queen H4 would be
Checkmate white king can never get onto
the f file and after a couple of useless
moves Santos thus is simply offered a
drive there's nothing to play for
because black can literally pre-move
Rook F3 and Rook F5 until the end of
humanity so it's just uh again
demonstrates the resilience that you
often see in end games even with like
one piece left on the board so if we
rewind back to the start the last thing
that I want to mention is the winning
line which does in fact start with the
only other logical move and that's Rook
takes G6 now Santos rejected this move I
think because he feared King F5 and he
thought that taking this useless Pawn on
G6 would only lose some Tempe for white
and it would allow black to generate
counter play ironically that's precisely
what he allowed with the move A5 here
the winning move is actually Rook to D6
simple idea Rook G2 is just met with
Rook D3 right sometimes you want to make
a couple of defensive moves and now the
game is over now the game is over
black can try to Stave off defeat
But ultimately uh White can win this in
a variety of ways such as bringing the
king closer and then blocking uh the the
B file and then at the right moment uh
the a file and the pawn is essentially
Home Free so that uh doesn't uh do all
that much there is nothing else the
plaque can do if he tries King E4 then
the clinical move is actually Rook D6 to
F6 I really like this geometry you go
Rook takes G6 to D6 to F6 cutting off
the king and you're aiming for F4 you
want to win the second Pawn which is
going to make the winning task so much
easier black cannot stop Rook F4 even
after King D5 you can throw in a check
to get black off of the opposition now
you play Rook F4 and that's it black
loses the second pawn and again I'll
leave it up to you to figure out how to
win that ensuing position but it's
totally winning
so Rook D6 is the winning move here Rook
to C6 may seem to do the same thing but
it allows black to give this additional
check on B2 here if the king moves back
then black can play Rook to G2 and the
pathway to the C3 square is blocked that
is why only Rook D6 wins the game not
Rook C6 definitely not something like
Rook G8 because this simply blunders the
pawn much like white did in the game but
really the highlight of the send game is
that a move as natural as A5 enables
black to save the draw always remember a
check even if you don't know exactly why
it's played can be such an effective
defensive tool in the end game in this
case it dislodges the king and no matter
where it goes black either stops the
pawn from behind or as in the game wins
White's Rock and then sets up a
beautiful Fortress a very unusual
Fortress that features two doubled puns
I have actually never seen this before I
was flipping out during the commentary
and uh you know you should never just
assume that queen versus Rook positions
are always going to be winning if there
are a couple of Pawns on the board then
you actually often can set up some sort
of impregnable Fortress that is what
Bortnick did in this game uh to save an
important half point for the Garden
State passer so ended up winning their
match against the Spanish Maniac
shrimpsu uh my team the Charlotte team
is facing next week we go full circle
and on that note folks this video did go
a little bit longer than I anticipated
but that's okay uh we were able to go
through all five of our instructive end
games uh we started with a simple
illustration of the potential danger of
making unnecessary pawn moves and
creating additional weaknesses then uh
we took a look at a fascinating tactical
end game never underestimate the power
of uh your few remaining pieces to
generate mating threats Queen B7 Queen
B2 there uh would have drawn the game
then we looked at the pawn end game uh
and discovered the power of timing the
pawn Advance correctly you often want to
time the pawn breakthrough uh to the
point where your opponent's king is on
the most inferior Square also Pawn races
simultaneous promotions we had it all in
this end game uh then we took a look at
the Double deflection that white could
have used in this game to win uh E6 and
then H6 and finally be concluded with
the Rook end game uh in uh no end game
video would be complete without a rook
end game in which white falls for the
temptation of making a natural move
always calculate always look at each end
game concretely whenever possible
hopefully you enjoyed this end game
Exposition I know that some of these
examples were pretty complicated but
thank you very much for watching the end
game series will continue as well with
another Knight versus pawns video and if
this video is well received I am more
than happy to do more of these kind of
end game Explorations from the PCL in
subsequent weeks well good luck to all
of the teams make sure to tune in next
week and I will see you in the next
video thank you for watching hope you
enjoyed
[Music]